ja dann begrüße ich sehr herzlich
günther beckstein bayerischer
ministerpräsident 2007 bis 2008 und
zuvor lange bayerischer innenminister
herr beckstein ich gebe die frage aus
dem beitrag den wir gesehen haben gleich
mal weiter ist der machtkampf die frage
wen die union als kanzlerkandidaten
aufstellt mit der entscheidung des
bundesvorstandes von heute nacht jetzt
entschieden
das ist möglich aber ich weiß es noch
nicht
ich gehe davon aus dass armin laschet
jetzt markus söder in dem
telefongespräch informieren wird wie das
gestern gelaufen ist ich gehe davon aus
dass markus söder auch und anrufe von
seinen unterstützern bekommen wird und
dann wird man sehen ob die cdu auch sich
an die entscheidung ihres engeren
bundesvorstandes hält die
bundestagsfraktion das akzeptiert wenn
die cdu das akzeptiert wird es nach
meiner einschätzung sicher auch von der
csu und markus söder akzeptiert werden
aber ich bin ruheständler und wird offen
stand auch froh darüber
herr nicht jetzt in der situation zu
sein aber herr beck sah man sie mich
nachfragen verstehe ich sie richtig
halten sie den bundesvorstand er heute
nacht ja ziemlich eindeutig mit einer
zweidrittelmehrheit sich inter armin
laschet gestellt hat 31 zu 9 stimmen ist
das nicht das legitimierte gremium über
um über die oder das gremium das über
die kanzlerfrage der union entscheiden
sollte und kann also das ist eine
entscheidung der cdu nicht der csu so
dass hier sehr klar gesagt dass der ball
im spielfeld der cdu liegt wenn die cdu
selber dass damit für entschieden hält
dann ist die entscheidung gefallen ob
das der fall ist kann ich im moment noch
nicht beurteilen ich weiß nicht ob es
bestrebungen gibt beispielsweise war
gestern die rede von einer
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz oder wie die
bunt wie die bundestagsfraktion das
akzeptiert aber es spricht vieles dafür
dass die entscheidung gefallen ist aber
bis soll das sich ernährt ist es noch
nicht sicher was denken sie denn will
er sich dann entscheiden sie kennen
markus söder ja sehr gut sie haben ihn
früh unterstützt sie sind beide kommen
weil aus franken wie wird er sich
entscheiden wird er jetzt einlenken
sie kann in der tat markus söder seit
vielen jahrzehnten
er ist gewohnt und war es nicht das
erste mal dass man nur durch eine harte
auseinandersetzung in ein amt kommt das
war hier das erste mal zum
landtagsabgeordneten gewählt worden ist
hatte der bezirksvorstand der csu eine
andere empfehlung gegeben hat sich
durchgesetzt auch ministerpräsident ist
ja nicht in durch eine friedliche
einvernehmliche ernennung geworden
sondern es war auch harte
auseinandersetzung also erst gewohnt
aber ich weiß auch dass markus eller
dann wenn eine entscheidung gefallen ist
sich kann hält deswegen ist es für mich
entscheiden dass wenn wir in den
nächsten tagen per wisst wer
kanzlerkandidat ist dass ich dann alle
daran halten spricht etliches dafür dass
das lasche des aber das wird erst sich
meines erachtens im laufe des heutigen
tages klären ob die cdu die entscheidung
des eigenen engeren vorstand das für
ausreichend sie sprechen die tagungen
der unionsfraktion der unionsfraktion an
heute die sich heute trifft die
abgeordneten der unionsfraktion
was glauben sie wird es da ein anderes
bild geben als gestern abend im
bundesvorstand
also ich sehe überall dieses offen
gestanden jetzt wichtig dass auf jeden
fall die entscheidung innerhalb der
nächsten zwei tage endgültig fällt und
das dann völlig jahres hinter wem man
sich stellt dass der wahlkampf ist ein
politischer streit ist manchmal
notwendig das ist demokratie die
richtige entscheidung wenn zwei leute
das wollen und das ist ja auch die
gewähr dafür dass der geeignetste dann
gewählt wird das war früher übrigens
auch die überzeugung der grünen noch
machen wir das in der zwischenzeit
anders aber wenn die entscheidung
gefallen ist müssen sich alle hinter dem
dann gewählten versammeln
wenn laschet die unterstützung seiner
partei
dann wird die csu wird er ihn auch
unterstützt man das ist auch notwendig
ist darf nicht sein dass zwei sich
streiten sich dann die dritte boll ja
herr beckstein die entscheidung wenn die
entscheidung gefallen ist sagen sie die
entscheidung ist ja gestern abend im
bundesvorstand gefallen das ist
eigentlich das legitimierte gremien
solche entscheidungen zu fällen und das
ganze ist ja auch schon mal vor einer
woche genau ähnlich sogar ein mutiger
entschieden wurden vom bundesvorstand
hat markus söder vor einer woche den
moment des fairplays verpasst hätte er
da nicht eigentlich schon zurückziehen
sollen denn so eine diskussion so ein
machtkampf auf offener bühne richtet
auch ziemlich vielen politischen schaden
an
also da hat vor einer woche erklärt dass
er kandidiert und er hat ja ganz
offensichtlich viele unterstützer im
bereich der cdu das wusste er wusste ja
zu welchen landesvorsitzenden welche
ministerpräsidenten hinter ihm stehen
und die werden ihn auch entsprechend
ermuntert haben und dann beschädigt dass
das durchaus verständlich dass man das
auslotet die frage ob die gestrige
entscheidung die klare entscheidung der
cdu war die markus söder erfordert das
müssen sie das selber fragen
das kann ich nicht abschließend
beurteilen aber es muss in jedem fall
jetzt in den nächsten stunden endgültige
entscheidung geklärt sein
sag ich mal wenn heute nachmittag auch
die bundestagsfraktion keine andere
entscheidung fällt dann gehe ich davon
aus dass es entschieden ist aber er
werde nicht ein
da müssten sie wir den haben selbst
fragen die er das vielleicht haben wir
dazu heute noch gelegenheit ich danke
ihnen sehr herzlich für das gespräch
herr werkstein alles gute danke